y un golpe de gracia a su rival y sube
al escenario reclamando ser la heredera
de margaret thatcher
ese legado implica recortar sino frenar
el poder de los sindicatos y reducir los
impuestos ahora tengo un plan para
convertir al reino unido en una economía
de alto crecimiento en los próximos diez
años mediante una aguda reforma de
oferta reduciremos los impuestos
ayudando a las empresas a invertir en su
futuro abordaremos el coste de la
energía y controlaremos el gasto público
3 ha sido la ministra de asuntos
exteriores de reino unido los últimos
tres años en este cargo hizo una serie
de declaraciones controvertidas una de
ellas recientemente cuando se le
preguntó por el presidente francés
presidente macrón amigo o enemigo
el jurado abandonó la sala white
los lazos con los vecinos europeos
fueron el quiebre de thatcher y han sido
durante mucho tiempo motivo de tensión
en el partido conservador tras voto a
favor de la permanencia de la unión
europea en 2016 pero en las elecciones
de líderes de este verano dijo que se
había equivocado una señora a favor de
los giros en esta mujer de 47 años
comenzó su vida política como liberal
demócrata mientras estudiaba en la
universidad de oxford y apoyó la
legalización del cannabis y la abolición
de la monarquía
sin embargo llegó a ser diputada
conservadora ocupando seis carteras
ministeriales bajo tres primeros
ministros
sucede a boris johnson con el reino
unido- luchando por encontrar su camino
después de un break si te es ordenado
una ola de huelgas inflación de dos
minutos y el partido laborista por
delante las encuestas no muy diferente
de cuando thatcher llegó al poder hace
décadas